Để xác định chưa của răng liệt cả hướng trên lộn rây rân mừng nữa,
thì ta sự rử dụng quý thách màn tay phải,
là dễ nhất khi sự dụng quý thách màn tay phải thì có 2 cách định xử lộn,
thấy thử rứng rân kèm cách nhất, cách tính lợi.
Các em là màn tay phải sau trong 1 tứ cậm tự bây tự suyên mà là màn.
Vết tự cậm tự bây tự suyên mà là màn.
Rồi làm thế rồi nhé, các bạn đờ màn tay vào đây, sau dụng bây tự cậm tự bây sự màn màn tay,
thẹn có 돌아 tự bây tự cậm tự bây tự có dây dụng hu res,
vậy cũng dụng vàn màn màn tay t государ thế này.
Nóan bây giờ, anh chỉ theo chiều của các người mà tôi quay em,
anh thấy các người mà tôi quay lại hướng từ phải xanh trái.
Tưởng rằng anh giải, đúng gặp, đồ, bài chiều từ cô, bài những vóan bây giờ,
chiều của giống liệt.
Bài chiều trong liệt của em sẽ của hướng tới...
Mờ, đến nợ.
Anh là chiều của giống liệt sẽ rướng từ mờ đến nợ.
Mờ đến nợ, bài chiều trong liệt,
chắc trong cái khu ngăn này trên nợ, bài.
Bài quyền!
Bài quyền mà!